ton oncle c'est huskel XL exactement qui
était donc c'était conducteur de la
voiture percutée comment il va
aujourd'hui toujours dans le coma
artificiel en réanimation là dessus
plein d'opérations
il dort toujours ils ont essayé de le
réveiller mais la douleur était trop
importante du coup pour l'instant
il a énormément d'organes touchés
ce qu'il faut savoir ça voilà
aujourd'hui il a subi donc cette
opération la comment réagit ta famille
aujourd'hui parce que c'est c'est un
drame c'est je l'ai dit encore hier il
est seul victime dans cette affaire
c'est c'est votre famille ce serait on
est vraiment triste parce que c'est un
truc qui arrive tout le temps quand vous
avez appris vous avez appris ça
justement comment comment vous avez
appris cette nouvelle et cet accident
comment on nous a appelé c'était le mari
de la femme qui était dans la voiture de
mon oncle nous appeler nous a dit
calmement que ils avaient fait un
accident pas grave mais il nous agit
d'aller sur les lieux et quand on est
allé avec plein d'ambulances hélicoptère
on nous a pas laissé aller le voir mais
on nous a dit les endroits des hôpitaux
pour aller les voir à quel moment vous
avez su que la faire aller être autant
médiatisé et que c'était une
personnalité qui avait percuté
devant l'hôpital de Beaujon il y avait
deux journalistes qui sont nuls je sais
pas comment mais ils m'ont reconnu ils
m'ont demandé comment allez mon oncle je
leur ai demandé qui était ils m'ont dit
qu'ils étaient des journalistes ils
m'ont dit vous savez que la personne qui
était impliquée a été vraiment connue
parce que je savais pas vous connaissiez
ou pas non pas du tout d'accord saviez
pas du tout non pas du tout ça continue
comme ça aujourd'hui ça sent ça change
rien pour vous voilà juste est-ce que
c'est pas
embêtant aussi pour la famille que la
faire aussi médiatisé bah si presque
toute ma famille a été impliquée dedans
ils vont chez mes oncles ou directement
dans ma ville pour savoir des
informations
il nous harcèle beaucoup au téléphone ou
un message on essaie de répondre à tout
le monde mais ça nous fatigue beaucoup
votre cousin des Dream il a 6 ans il est
à l'hôpital Necker actuellement est-ce
qu'il est réveillé des vrais des fois il
se réveille mais avec des douleurs du
coup ils redor
il a la mâchoire cassée
il a une mineure là et ils vont essayer
de le mettre en Corse et vers lundi ou
mardi
je crois qu'ils ont dit qu'il a quand il
a vu sa maman il
le soir même ça m'a allé le voir t'es
pas réveillé il y a deux jours ils l'ont
réveillé sa mère est allé revoir ça lui
a changé un peu les idées on va dire
parce que avant ça il avait pas
d'émotions et quand il avait sa mère il
a sauvé un peu sur le aujourd'hui le
pronostic vital n'est engagé pour les
deux non voilà non pour l'enfant
est tellement intense
et visiblement enfin il y aura pas de
séquelles cérébral pour le pour votre
cousin ce que j'ai pas du tout il y a
beaucoup de vertiges
sur la tête sur ce qui lui fait tourner
la tête
il arrive pas vraiment parlé il se
souvient de ce qui lui est arrivé ou pas
du tout non pas du tout pas du tout on a
voulu demander mais il a pleuré à chaque
fois du coup on a arrêté de lui demander
c'est de très difficile aussi pour votre
temps qui a perdu son bébé oui elle
venait de se marier après un an c'était
son premier enfant ça devait choquant
pour elle son mari
est-ce que elle est dans quel état
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas vraiment
d'informations sur elle parce que
j'étais vraiment
focalisé sur mon oncle qui avait un état
plus grave on va dire du coup j'étais
plus avec mon oncle que ma porte
alors votre famille suit le volet
judiciaire bien sûr de la faire
vous attendez quoi je sais
j'utilise parfaite qui soit condamné
responsable en fait de prendre la drogue
aller sur la route en faisant ça il a
risqué la vie de plusieurs personnes
ça aurait pu être plus grave
aujourd'hui vous avez vu qu'il n'a pas
été mis en détention provisoire et c'est
la règle c'est la loi qui dit ça c'est
vraiment il y a pas eu de
passe-droit
vous avez réagi comment cette on était
stupéfait il a fait un acte
qui devait se passer autrement ils
devaient être condamnés rapidement et
très rapidement en fait mais avec un
bracelet je pense qu'il pourra faire
autre chose
s'il est avec un bracelet il a une
limite de zone il pourra reprendre la
drogue on sait jamais avec lui
parce qu'on parlait avec George Fennec
il y a un instant qui disait si l'on
remis en liberté voilà c'est parce que
il pense qu'il n'aurait pas de récidive
c'est ça il considère qu'il y a pas de
récidive enfin qui aurait pas dressing
c'est pas grave hein exactement bien sûr
que c'est la bonne décision c'est la
décision qui a été prise des surgues
conformément voilà et aux expertises
voilà c'est ça vous voulez le moment du
jugement il encourt une peine très
sévère bien sûr quelle peine
[Musique]
finalement il va se retrouver dans des
conditions de confinement comme on l'a
tous vécu pendant le covid avec un
bracelet électronique mais cette famille
elle c'est le parallèle et je trouve un
supportable
encore une fois désolé mais la détention
provisoire ce n'est pas une sanction
comprenez bien sûr mais les faits
qui va durer au moins un an
d'instruction donc là il est assigné il
peut pas sortir c'est une espèce de
détention à domicile vous comprenez
merde
quand on s'assoit tu dis quoi
bah c'est pas la vraie justice qu'on
veut en fait ah ouais
alors comment vous avez réagi avec ta
famille aux excuses de Pierre Palmade
les excuses vont pas ramener l'enfant
moral à la vie ils vont paraître ni la
mâchoire de mon cousin
c'est pas des excuses valables tout le
monde peut faire pareil faire les mêmes
actes et s'excuser après donc pour vous
c'est pour votre famille ils disent quoi
ici eux ils pensent même pas ça ils
pensent d'abord au rétablissement de
différents membres et surtout à la peine
de votre tente qui a perdu son bébé quoi
c'est ça
on peut pas imaginer des excuses après
avoir fait des comme ça tout le monde
peut faire des actes et s'excuser mais
c'est pas valable maintenant il faut il
faut aussi attendre dans 10 jours
qui avait requis la détention de la pop
tenue et donc il y aura un appel devant
la chambre d'instruction dans les juges
de la Cour d'appel dans une dizaine de
jours et et on sait pas on peut avoir
une appréciation différente ce qui a
étonné quand même c'est que vous le
disiez il risque 7 à 10 ans mais avec la
récidive légale ça pourrait doubler qui
pourrait rester
dit le procureur donc
ça aurait été déjà un premier accident
sous l'emprise
au sens légal du terme genre j'ai raison
aujourd'hui Homer qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que tu as envie de dire ce
soir parce que tu sais que tu es
extrêmement ému qu'on est vraiment
triste
c'est pas un acte qu'on devait recevoir
ni nous ni personne d'autre
on est en colère aussi parce que c'est
un acte responsable déjà quand on monte
dans la voiture on prend toute la
responsabilité de ce qu'on fait il a
vraiment été responsable
et on est triste on espère qu'il comme
mon oncle est mon cousin serait
d'abriant rapidement comme ma tante ils
ont peut-être des problèmes
psychologiques maintenant
elle doit être détruite elle a perdu son
enfant comme la femme à mon oncle qui a
toujours pas vu son mari
ça je suis complètement